[Musique]
après Sainte-Suzanne braspanon 3 bassins
et le tampon c'est à Saint-Pierre que le
forum territorialisé de l'action sociale
et de l'insertion s'est installé ce
jeudi 20 avril organisé à l'initiative
du département en lien avec la ville de
Saint-Pierre cette manifestation
destinée au public en recherche
d'insertion et d'accompagnement social à
réuni les services de la collectivité
mais aussi les différents partenaires
sociaux comme le CCAS de la ville la CAF
ou encore le Pôle Emploi une journée
centrée cette fois-ci sur le numérique
inclusif aujourd'hui on est à
Saint-Pierre au jardin de la plage avec
tous les partenaires autour de nous
c'est important de travailler de façon
coordonnée avec tous nos partenaires et
pour être aussi à la portée de tous nos
publics aujourd'hui tout passe par le
numérique mais on a encore des publics
qui en sont éloignés donc on
au niveau du département ça nous tient à
cœur de mettre en place cet
accompagnement mais un accompagnement
coordonné de façon à ce que nos publics
puissent aussi être à l'aise avec cet
outil et parfaire leur parcours vers la
réussite avec ses nombreuses stands
d'information mais aussi des espaces
d'animation des prestations bien-être ou
encore des ateliers thématiques ce forum
répond à la volonté du département
d'aller vers les publics en grande
difficulté tout en s'adaptant aux
spécificités de chaque territoire
d'action sociale les indicateurs sociaux
sont en rouge sur les terres sud-ouest
que ce soit le nombre de chômeurs plus
de 37% de taux de chômage que ce soit le
nombre de familles
monoparentales que ce soit le nombre de
bénéficiaires du RSA on est à plus de
22000 sur les territoires donc c'est
vrai avec une précarité monétaire
importante donc c'est vrai que la
situation sociale sur le
sud-ouest et quand même pareil sur au
niveau du département une situation
sociale hors norme l'ambition de ce
forum c'était vraiment de réunir sur
place à le plus grand nombre de
partenaires qui interviennent dans le
champ de l'action sociale et de
l'insertion justement pour pouvoir dans
la proximité apporter toutes les
réponses nécessaires pour un mieux
accompagner nos publics qui sont en
difficulté et qui sont dans la recherche
d'une insertion sociale et
professionnelle sur place les visiteurs
ont pu disposer d'informations
d'orientation et de conseils sur leurs
droits les dispositifs d'accompagnement
vers l'insertion et les aides
financières du département je commence à
prendre des choses c'est pour mon fils
qui a 18 ans et puis il est en échec
scolaire j'ai appris que bon en fait qui
pouvait le suivre pour faire
des stages enfin des formations au
niveau du conseil général du département
etc et qui sera aussi rémunéré après et
il sera aussi à l'internat pendant
[Musique]
l'argent en plus selon les contrats et
sinon ouais ça a l'air sympa il y a d'un
peu et donne un petit coup de main et on
a besoin de ça d'ailleurs le public a pu
assister à la mise en pratique de ce
dispositif d'allocation de retour à
l'emploi l'un des dispositifs phares de
la collectivité en matière d'insertion
avec la signature d'un contrat r+, entre
le département un demandeur d'emploi et
un employeur
[Musique]
pour ceux qui n'auraient pas pu assister
à cette journée rassurez-vous le forum
territorialisé de l'action sociale et de
l'insertion vous donnera à nouveau
rendez-vous sur le tas sud-ouest d'ici
la fin d'année 2023
[Musique]